hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to among the sleep now
whoa all right let me just slam my hands
down on the ground as fast as possible
cuz I'm a man I'm a man baby I'm a I'm a
baby man I'm a Batman baby I'm a baby
man okay who are them those aren't the
colors that I were associated with mom
and dad before maybe that maybe that
might be mom I don't know who that is
who's the redhead all right this is
bizarre can I ride by horsey
okay these are weird fragments of
memories to be having why is this a
thing anything in here I need in this
big creepy closet
hmm well alright then it's a good thing
I went in here hesitant okay great great
can I go back to bed now sugar should I
go back to my little baby bed
am I missing anybody wasn't there like a
fourth person standing around the glow
before Oh get out of here okay I don't
like this it's really dark and scary
okay okay
was there an upstairs I think I recall
yeah there was an upstairs okay so I
need to go okay I'm going now go cause
like tier day I'm going I'm running fast
my toddler freaking carry me okay
there's a light I'm moving in there's a
basement - I didn't go down into the
basement I'll go down into the basement
afterwards because Basin is probably a
final place it doesn't happen - oh no oh
no I gotta go in the basement now but I
wanna go in the basement now the beat
the beat man is filled with dastardly
demons and horrible horrible nests it's
gonna be bad news but you're gonna be
there with me right you're gonna be
there with me the whole time right guys
I'm just gonna have my little ball with
me I'm gonna roll the ball down the
stairs first just for safety all right
whoa okay let's turn that back on thank
you
yeah
Oh
huh
oh yeah okay oh good
no thanks I'll be over here just
cowering in the corner horrible I do
oh I'm gonna cower here sorry about me
oh oh yeah oh god oh god oh it's so
scary
hi hi hi hi oh I've been munched had
been crunching munch oh I literally got
crunchy munched what does that mean
can I move it no no you did I oh okay
oh good it spawned me right here here we
go I'm a-goin gonna give me you're gonna
give me ain't gonna give me
I don't know what about it I don't what
huh huh I'm a little confused I'm a
little dazed and confused right now I
don't I don't I don't don't know what
I'm supposed to do about that
hmm okay I think I know what I need to
do now okay I got oh yeah oh yeah I
guess oh yeah come after me bro don't
come after me
whoops sorry almost add that excuse me
everybody I'm just I'm trying to I'm
trying to trying to get through this so
uh don't criticize me my skill is uh not
in question here well my skill is a lot
in question and most of what I do
hey you out there sigh I have some
skills I'm great at blood-borne I'm
fantastic at blood-borne I mean I
thought I was gonna do a series on
blood-borne they just kept playing it on
my own and maybe maybe in the future for
a life term something but I'm like I'm
like ludicrously good at blood-borne
right now it's not like me bragging or
anything like I'm just so amazingly good
at it like there's no way anybody ever
would ever whatever doubt my skill a
blood-borne I'm just gonna take the
stool here yeah that's that's that's
what I want
so that thing doesn't like me being in
the light okay we're good we're good
we're good we're good
good we're good okay all right okay all
right okay
all right we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good here get up
get up get up get up come on come on
come on yeah yeah come on Baba dooba
dooba dooba dooba never do Baba do with
that bubble hello thank you thank you no
thank you no thank you no thank you
all right so do I just get out of here
now
am I free to go I'm free to go so now
that I got Oh hurry turn on the light oh
I didn't realize how I humble that I
fell man I swear this basement was like
the creepiest basement ever
you guys are still with me right right
hey okay everyone's good everyone's
having a great time
you son-of-a-bitch
hmm I don't like that I like that man so
much detail when in this game how many
things have I missed have I missed eyes
like that okay okay okay me hey Sanna
how dare you how dare you come this
early from Christmas okay cool
that doors locked
cry for the best that's why where I'm
going to go die although I'm not gonna
die because this kid thought I was 9
oh I thought that I saw that I saw that
there's no doubt been so many things
that I've missed around here hello baby
coming through don't mind the baby
everybody loves me oh I always like
going towards the loud thumping
heartbeat now can only mean good things
hey wait a minute I'm the only baby
around here nobody better be moving in
on my territory
how pound eerie how dare you how dare
you wait oh okay I knew it I know what I
need to do
who was that who's that who said that
those were adult words there's only
babies allowed here friend and for a big
ol fall into the snow all dammit wait a
minute oh oh there's choices of which
way to go and I went the wrong way I
need to go not the wrong way you you'll
be do okay I think that might be the
last one I'm not mistaken cuz I
collected four already and I think there
was a maximum of five people around that
certain he lit up
all right let's see what you got come on
come on come on get up on that thank you
boy
this baby is gonna be so buff by the
time he's done he's gonna be almost as
buff as I was when I was a baby and I
was a baby I was ten pounds three ounces
of pure muscle as a baby those me how
big were you as a baby just to ask you
guys a thump broken legs hello Bonnie
Bonnie no oh okay well okay bye
Oh No are you about to hit her oh this
is all sad who's coming up the stairs
who's coming up the stairs okay no one
okay all right we're fine so I think you
got to go outside and find the bun bun
cuz I can't leave the bun bun who's a
ding dong
who's a ding Li Dingling who's a ding
ding something up here that I need
scribble Scrabble can't read that it
might be a picture I can grab uh-oh it's
the family before every oh ow I am NOT
the prettiest baby but hey Who am I to
judge
all right whoa whoa hey whoa hey okay
oh no moving oh you this before you
moved
oh this before to move is that teddy
bear that's that's the voice of teddy
bear ate it oh okay okay okay okay okay
okay I outta good are you following me
you better not be following me you have
a queue [ __ ] off will you better do word
bun-bun go
fun bun weird bun man we're bun but
we're bun bun bun bun bun bun bun one
bond was out here we're bun bun where
was one man who bun buns bunny Oh
bun buns bunny Bo one bun one who that's
what I was doing
oh that's what I was doing it was a
flashback from a flashback Oh
i'm-a-comin I'm a common I'm a waddling
as quickly as I can you you left your
bow your bows went really Wow yeah yeah
hello bunny buddy
bunbun Hey
hey Manny no Robbie that's too much
okay all right cool
I guess that's it then well there you
have it god they're so good at making a
terrifying experience they're so good
it's so good it's so good god is so good
oh man is so good man okay I really hope
you guys have seen the original among
the sleep series and I really hope that
there's more among the sleep being made
or at least by this team there's another
horror game that they're making in the
future because it's really good idea
it's a really good idea I love it to
death it's phenomenal
love it love it love it thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other cool series that I've done in
the past in the description below
I recommend outlast and I recommend
amnesia or any of them so thank you
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
just said at least I have our hearings
being dragged away I don't like that
Paranormal Activity wanted
the handed was I supposed to do that the
music stuff